durante muchos años décadas incluso las
ricas sociald democracias nórdicas
fueron consideradas como el refugio
perfecto para la inmigración sin que
importara el origen la raza la religión
ni ninguna otra condición la mayoría de
estos países se construyeron con la
llegada de centenares de miles de
extranjeros sin embargo desde hace algún
tiempo todo esto ha empezado a cambiar
radicalmente la política migratoria ha
sido incluso decisiva a la hora de
promover cambios de gobierno por ejemplo
la mitad de los cuatro países nórdicos
continentales ya no están en manos de
partidos socialdemócratas los gobiernos
conservadores se han abierto paso en
Suecia y Finlandia y en Dinamarca el
gobierno está formado por una gran
coalición formada por socialdemócratas y
liberal conservadores Claro que en este
último caso quizá te sorprenda pero
hablamos de un país que ya lleva años
siendo particularmente duro contra la
inmigración ilegal y muy restrictivo con
las políticas de refugiados y todo ello
sin importar realmente quien gobierne
fijaos mete frederiksen el rostro de la
izquierda anti inmigración en Dinamarca
defensora de una política de cero
refugiados su gobierno ha llevado a cabo
un controvertido proyecto para reubicar
a los solicitantes de asilo en Ruanda
mientras se procesan sus solicitudes el
país también ha revocado los permisos de
residencia sirios procedentes de
regiones que considera seguras y claro
puede que en este punto muchos de
vosotros os estéis preguntando por qué
Por qué los países nórdicos que
tradicionalmente han sido tan abiertos y
tan tolerantes con la llegada de
migrantes ahora están cambiando
radicalmente de tono y lo que resulta
aún más importante Qué tipo de políticas
se están poniendo en marcha y por qué
hablamos de ellas aquí en al politic
acaso puede ser esto el anticipo de lo
que está por venir en los próximos años
Pues bien estas y muchas otras preguntas
os las vamos a responder a continuación
Así que gasolina y arranquemos
por cierto si os gusta lo que hacemos y
queréis recibir más contenido exclusivo
y ayudarnos a crecer no olvidéis que
podéis echarnos una mano en el patreon
de visual politic con patreon recibiréis
boletines contenido exclusivo
merchandising también exclusivo y muchas
más cosas que estamos preparando y claro
por supuesto nos ayudarás a seguir
creciendo por ejemplo la llegada de
visual nomic tuvo mucho pero que mucho
que ver con vuestro apoyo en patreon os
dejo el enlace en la descripción
Muchísimas gracias a todos los que ya
nos apoyáis mes tras mes y también Cómo
no a los que estáis al otro lado de la
pantalla cada día y dicho esto vamos con
el
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vídeo La primera pregunta que creo que
tenemos que responder es por qué Por qué
los nórdicos cada vez son más reacios
con el tema de la inmigración qué
diantes ha pasado para que se produzca
semejante cambio Pues bien Lo cierto es
que la respuesta es compleja Y hay
muchas variables involucradas por
ejemplo la insuficiente capacidad de
integración de tantas personas de
culturas tan diferentes puede estar
provocando como veremos algunos
problemas de seguridad pero con mucha
diferencia lo que más ha influido en
este cambio de paradigma tiene que ver
con el estado de bienestar sin duda la
columna vertebral del modelo de cohesión
social de estos países no es ningún
secreto en Suecia Finlandia Noruega
Dinamarca e Islandia el estado juega un
un rol central en la protección de las
personas es con mucho la característica
más conocida de los países nórdicos
básicamente si naces en uno de estos
países es casi seguro que no tendrás
problema para acceder a la atención
sanitaria a un hogar a una pensión o a
subsidios de todo tipo Especialmente
cuando hablamos de natalidad este
gráfico nos lo deja muy
claro para que osjes una idea los cinco
países nórdicos están en el top 10 de
los países con más gasto sobre el pib en
educación y sanidad y en el podium
encontramos dos Islandia y Dinamarca
lógicamente estos elefantiásica estados
de bienestar se tienen que financiar de
alguna forma por ejemplo vía impuestos
los países nórdicos tienen una presión
fiscal de más del 40% y evidentemente
que sean economías históricamente ricas
avanzadas y muy competitivas también
ayuda a tener unos servicios públicos de
primera esto implica que en estos países
un alto porcentaje de los trabajadores
son profesionales altamente cualificados
con salarios elevados algo que facilita
que el estado pueda recaudar mucho y
mantener altísimas prestaciones sociales
sin limitar excesivamente el poder
adquisitivo de sus trabajadores y la
competitividad de sus empresas ahora
bien cuál es el problema Pues el
problema es que una parte muy grande de
la inmigración que han recibido estos
países en los últimos años son personas
sin una buena formación educativa ni
profesional Y eso limita mucho su
contribución fiscal al tiempo que además
tiende a consumir más recursos
públicos la falta de cualificación
además conlleva serios problemas para
Acceder al mercado laboral Pese a que
hablamos de países con niveles de
desempleo muy reducido y eso no es todo
dado que en estos países las
prestaciones sociales suelen ser muy
altas en ocasiones provocan un efecto
desplazamiento digamos que puede llegar
a ser más rentable recibir subsidios que
tener un empleo de baja cualificación el
problema es que esto a la larga provoca
problemas de integración mucha más
economía sumergida y también el
surgimiento de grupos criminales que de
hecho sobre esto último ya os hablamos
en un pasado vídeo sobre Suecia si
estáis viendo Este vídeo pues me da la
impresión de que también os va a
interesar mucho así que os dejo el
enlace en la
[Aplausos]
descripción El caso es que por estos
motivos El Gran aumento de la
inmigración que ha tenido lugar en
Europa en los últimos años ha impactado
mucho más en los asistencialistas
estados nórdicos que en el resto además
pensad de un momento el incentivo de la
gente para ir a países con tantos
subsidios es enorme lo que lógicamente
ha conllevado también un importante
aumento del gasto social en estos países
y luego si a todo esto le sumamos además
el incremento de refugiados registrado
desde el estallido de la Guerra de
Ucrania el cóctel se pone aún más amargo
queridos amigos amigas todo esto que os
estamos contando ha tenido dos efectos
muy claros por un lado los nórdicos
están viendo como sus servicios públicos
y su estado de bienestar se están
degradando básicamente porque cada vez
hay más más demandantes demandantes que
en la mayoría de los casos no han
aportado nada o muy poco al sistema lo
que a corto y medio plazo genera un
importante Gap estructural y por otro
tenemos el efecto económico y financiero
ya que algunos países han tenido que
optar o bien por recortar las
prestaciones o bien por Aumentar los
impuestos Noruega aumenta los impuestos
en 3000 millones de dólares a las
empresas eléctricas y piscifactorías los
costes relacionados con la acogida de
refugiados los proyectos de construcción
pública en curso el pago de prestaciones
y los subsidios a la electricidad de los
hogares aumentarán en unos 100,000
millones de coronas en 2023 según ha
afirmado el gobierno hablamos de un
escenario que está empezando a provocar
mucho
malestar y precisamente para frenar esta
deriva las viejas y conocidas social
democracias nórdicas están endureciendo
los requisitos para acceder a las
prestaciones públicas al tiempo que
también están acabando con su política
de puertas abiertas y su trad ional
tolerancia con la inmigración el nuevo
gobierno de Finlandia anuncia un cambio
de paradigma con medidas energéticas
contra la inmigración los permisos de
residencia concedidos bajo protección
internacional pasarán a ser temporales y
su duración se reducirá al mínimo de la
Unión Europea en el futuro serán
revocados y una persona está de
vacaciones en su país de origen también
pretende establecer sistemas separados
de prestaciones de seguridad Social para
inmigrantes y residentes permanentes
ahora bien si todo esto que os estamos
contando no os parece suficiente esperad
un momento porque no hemos hecho nada
más que empezar los países nórdicos
reforzarán la colaboración en materia de
deportaciones de inmigrantes un objetivo
común es garantizar la deportación de
extranjeros sin permiso de residencia a
sus países de origen el 31 de octubre de
2023 los cinco países nórdicos firmaron
tres iniciativas que suponen un paso más
en este completo cambio de paradigma
Hablamos de una nueva estrategia para
promover la salida voluntaria de
inmigrantes y refugiados así como la
expulsión de inmigrantes
ilegales
ahora bien incluso teniendo en cuenta
este cambio lo cierto Es que hay un país
en concreto que está siendo con mucha
diferencia el más duro a la hora de
intentar atajar los problemas que se han
causado en las últimas décadas un país
en el que la mano dura es un consenso
general entre todas las fuerzas
políticas hablamos de Dinamarca lo que
os vamos a contar a continuación puede
que os sorprenda a muchos y sobre todo
puede que cambie un poco la opinión o la
imagen que tenéis del país del Lego y el
regaliz Dinamarca apenas tres décadas
Era uno de los países más abiertos a la
inmigración y a los refugiados de toda
Europa y quizás de todo el mundo también
era uno de los que más ayudas ponía
sobre la mesa sin embargo de esa
Dinamarca ya no queda ni la sombra y
claro La pregunta es de qué hablamos
exactamente cuando decimos que Dinamarca
usa la mano dura será acaso el alumno
aventajado que está marcando el camino
de una nueva política en toda Europa
Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
o por las buenas o por las
malas como ya hemos dicho Dinamarca es
con diferencia el país de los nórdicos
que ha adoptado un enfoque más radical
contra la inmigración ilegal es el país
más duro de la región nórdica Y quizá lo
es de toda Europa y para empezar Esto no
es algo estrictamente nuevo no es una
decisión que se haya tomado ante ayer
precisamente y prueba de ello son los
acuerdos que Dinamarca firmó pero más
importante los que no firmó en el marco
de la Unión Europea y es que veréis
después de que los daneses rechazas en
un primer referéndum el tratado de
maastrich que es uno de los tratados
fundacionales de la Unión Europea las
autoridades comunitarias acordaron con
copenhague cuatro cláusulas de exclusión
voluntaria de ellas dos mantienen su
validez y aplicación real actualmente
fijaos en primer lugar los daneses no
adoptarían el euro y se quedarían con la
corona danesa lo cual evidentemente no
es relevante para el tema del que
estamos hablando pero la segunda en
cambio sí que es mucho más importante y
es que Dinamarca también está exenta de
cumplir la mayor parte de las leyes y
obligaciones europeas en materia entre
otros de asilo y de reparto de de
refugiados inmigrantes irregulares Esto
es algo que se acordó en 1997 con el
tratado de amsterdam y desde entonces lo
cierto es que los daneses han hecho casi
lo que han querido con su política
migratoria ahora bien sabéis Cuál es el
mayor exponente de todo esto pues ni más
ni menos que su política de cero
refugiados sí lo habéis oído
bien hasta la Guerra de Ucrania
Dinamarca apenas aceptó refugiados y a
los que aceptó como es el caso de
algunos sirios que huían de la guerra
ahora los está empezando a invitar a
marcharse incluso a varios cientos de
ellos directamente los ha expulsado al
considerar que sus regiones de origen ya
son zonas seguras para que os hagáis una
idea en términos per cápita por cada
refugiado que llega a Dinamarca llegan
seis a Alemania y a Suecia en 2021 antes
de la Guerra de Ucrania solo había
36,000 refugiados en el país y en 2020
el país registró el menor número de
solicitudes de asilo en 20 años poco más
de 1500 evidentemente todo esto responde
a una política muy hostil hacia este
tipo de migraciones para empezar en 2016
el gobierno danés aprobó una ley
popularmente conocida como la la ley de
la joyería una ley que fue aprobada por
una amplia mayoría del parlamento 81 de
109 diputados donde además estaba
incluido el partido socialdemócrata que
ya en ese momento estaba liderado por la
actual primera ministra mete fredriksen
ahora bien En qué consiste esta ley Pues
agarraos a la
Silla resumiendo mucho la llamada ley de
joyería obliga a los solicitantes de así
los recién llegados al país a que
entreguen al Estado danés sus objetos de
valor como una forma de pagar su
Estancia incluidas joyas y oro a
excepción de alguna pieza limitada que
pueda tener un particular valor
sentimental la ley también Establece que
los refugiados que lleguen al país con
más de 10,000 coronas algo menos de
1,500 tienen que contribuir con los
costes de su alojamiento y además la ley
también dificulta y mucho las reuniones
familiares los solicitantes de asilo
tienen que esperar al menos 3 años para
poder solicitar poder llevar a sus
familias a Dinamarca todo esto
obviamente tiene como objetivo
desincentivar que los refugiados elijan
Dinamarca como opción ya que hay muchas
otras opciones en Europa con mejores
condiciones de acogida y lo cierto Es
que en este sentido la ley con las
cifras en la mano está funcionando para
muchos esta ley es inhumana y racista
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que el
gobierno danés o sorpresa no aplicó nada
de eso a los refugiados ucranianos que
llegaron huyendo de la guerra para otros
sin embargo Es una herramienta clave
para evitar la formación de getos y de
sociedades paralelas que es el motivo
fundamental con el que los políticos
tanto de izquierdas como de derechas la
justifican pero es que aún hay más mucho
más por ejemplo cuando un inmigrante o
refugiado recibe una orden de expulsión
del país y no coopera con las
autoridades en Dinamarca se le interna
en un centro de retorno donde está
obligado a residir Y pernotar cada noche
Supongo que llamarles centros de
expulsión quedaba pues menos estético
Pues bien el país cuenta con al menos
tres centros de retorno para extranjer
os en los que en algunos casos algunos
extranjeros pasan largas temporadas es
una espera con un destino incierto y ojo
no estamos hablando de centros de
internamiento temporal de inmigrantes
ilegales recién llegados eso lo podemos
encontrar en muchos países aquí hablamos
de extranjeros que ya estaban en
Dinamarca pero que por cualquier motivo
se les ha ordenado la expulsión además
en estos centros se les aplica un
régimen de conducta disciplina y normas
muy estrictas y si no las cumplen hay un
régimen de castigos que prevé multas e
incluso la prisión Pero bueno con todo
Si hay una medida polémica que radical
entre todas las que os hemos contado y
os vamos a contar es la que Dinamarca ha
tomado en contra de los guetos de
extranjeros o como les gusta llamarlo a
ellos las sociedades paralelas y es que
veréis tal y como os hemos comentado en
el vídeo que hicimos sobre Suecia uno de
los problemas que dificulta la
integración de muchos inmigrantes es su
concentración en zonas donde apenas
tienen contacto con la sociedad local
hablamos de barrios llenos de viviendas
públicas que se le entregaron a estos
inmigrantes por considerarlos colectivos
vulnerables barrios en los que se
terminan creando comunidades cerradas
con super propia cultura costumbres y a
veces de facto incluso sus propias leyes
hablamos de espacios donde en muchos
casos el contacto de sus vecinos con la
población local de los países de acogida
es nulo incluso hablamos de lugares
donde buena parte de la población
residente extranjera no tiene empleos
regulares o termina dedicándose
actividades delictivas y claro la
exclusión conduce a más exclusión y eso
nunca termina En nada bueno en ese
sentido estas zonas son las que han
servido como caldo de cultivo para el
crimen organizado en países como Suecia
países donde están experimentando un
inédito problema de seguridad que está
superando a las propias
[Música]
autoridades Pues bien Dinamarca es el
país europeo Y puede que del mundo
incluso que más duramente le ha
declarado la guerra a estas zonas
gatificar a estas sociedades paralelas
por ejemplo en 2018 Dinamarca aprobó una
polémica ley cuya mayor iniciativa
consiste en reorganizar y rediseñar
barrios pobres de vivienda pública que
tengan una alta concentración de
inmigrantes antes no occidentales con un
plazo límite 2030 un plan que fue
anunciado por un gobierno conservador
pero que ha sido puesto en marcha por el
gobierno socialdemócrata de frederiksen
ahora bien En qué consiste esta
reorganización Pues básicamente en
entrar en esos barrios para hacerse con
las casas en algunos casos incluso
entrar con bulldozers para demoler
viviendas públicas Sí sí lo habéis
escuchado bien previamente el gobierno
danés llevó a cabo el realojo forzoso de
sus vecinos que en algunos casos como os
podéis imaginar se resiste a irse de sus
casas Dinamarca envía la bola de
demolición a los barrios no occidentales
un programa gubernamental está
utilizando las demoliciones y los
realojos para rehacer barrios con
inmigrantes pobreza o crimen en concreto
la ley exige que en los barrios en los
que al menos la mitad de la población
sea de origen o ascendencia no
occidental la proporción de viviendas
públicas no puede superar el 40% del
[Música]
total para declarar una zona como sus
ible de actuación la ley indica que se
tienen que dar al menos dos de las
siguientes características bajos
ingresos malos resultados educativos
alto desempleo o alto porcentaje de
habitantes con condenas penales uno de
los lugares que sirve como ejemplo de
geto es el barrio de miula pacun donde
el 43 por de sus residentes están
desempleados el 82 por tiene origen no
occidental el 53 por tiene escasa
educación y el 51 tiene ingresos Bajos
en la práctica esto significa que de
aquí a 2030 el gobierno danés tendrá que
derribar o en su defecto aciar y
revender a otras personas más de 4,000
viviendas públicas en barrios como ese a
día de hoy alrededor de medio millar ya
han sido demolidas y muchas de las que
no son demolidas y se decide
conservarlas se venden a inversores que
las rehabilitan y luego las venden a
precio de Mercado a nuevos habitantes
con mayor poder adquisitivo en la
práctica La idea es relocalizar y diluir
a la población inmigrante dentro de la
sociedad danesa evitando que los
extranjeros se concentren en zonas
concretas se aíslen del resto de la
sociedad y por tanto no se integren
conceptualmente la idea no es mala Lo
que sí es más controvertido es el
enfoque forzoso y obligatorio que se le
ha dado en Dinamarca adoptamos el punto
de vista básico de que concentrar los
problemas sociales aumenta los problemas
sociales no creemos que sea bueno crecer
en un vecindario donde hay muchos
problemas sociales y relacionados con la
integración por supuesto me imagino que
aquí habrá opiniones para todos los
[Música]
gustos pero aún no hemos terminado aún
hay más aparte de esta política de
vivienda y realojo Dinamarca también
obliga a que los niños pequeños de estas
zonas pasen al menos 25 horas semanales
en centros preescolares donde se les
enseña el idioma danés y cito
literalmente los valores daneses y
aunque todavía es pronto para saber si
estas medidas funcionarán o fracasará lo
que sí sabemos es que Dinamarca se está
convirtiendo en una especie de
laboratorio para muchos países europeos
con problemas similares Claro que uno de
los riesgos que existen y no es un
riesgo precisamente menor Es que la
política de realojos forzosos y de mano
dura contra los refugiados y la
inmigración ilegal aumente el
sentimiento de desarraigo cuando una
persona se siente muy desarraigada
señalada y estigmatizada por la sociedad
que le rodea puede en algunos casos
desarrollar una rabia y un odio que
puede dar lugar a mayores niveles de
radicalización y comportamientos fuera
de la ley obviamente Esto es algo que
las autoridades danesas saben y que
tendrán que vigilar es un riesgo
potencialmente muy importante que hay
que tener en cuenta el caso amigos
amigas es que en Dinamarca a día de hoy
el concepto multiculturalismo era un
rechazo social importante en Dinamarca
multiculturalismo Es realmente una
palabra negativa En otras palabras que
en la tierra de La Sirenita ser un
Forastero que no ha sido invitado podría
conducirte de cabeza a tener que nadar
en aguas más turbulentas y ojo porque lo
que os hemos contado del país nórdico
anti inmigración por excelencia no es
más que lo que podría estar a punto de
empezar a suceder en otros como Suecia o
Finlandia cuyos gobiernos recientemente
han girado a la derecha la pregunta
llegados hasta aquí es funcionarán todos
estos planes por ahora el debate os lo
dejamos servido a todos vosotros Así que
dejadnos vuestra opinión por aquí abajo
en los comentarios y muy importante si
os ha gustado este vídeo no olvidéis
darle a like y suscribiros a nuestro
canal para no perderos ninguna novedad
también os recordamos que tenemos un
patreon a través del cual podéis
ayudarnos a seguir creciendo y mejorando
a cambio de contenidos ventajas y
regalos exclusivos os dejamos el link
aquí abajo en la descripción una vez más
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la
próxima